[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is our daily live show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy fandom news
you need to know and it's Friday baby
we're so happy to be here coming up on
the show today we got She-Hulk updates
Dwayne Johnson's has some feelings on
Marvel oh boy we might catch him in his
feelings I don't know Dunes shooting
they shoot shoot left I made you look
uh and Halloween ends reviews we have
some reviews the concept of reviews yeah
I'm done with reviews they're done we
will not be reviewing the holiday
anymore and folks because it's Friday
and things are different in the MCU now
we got
sexy dirty and some real filthy fan
fictional reads for you guys uh so you
might want to stick around for that one
uh uh I'm Brandon Barrack who cares
across the table we got koi chandro
people are ready for this this fanfic I
hope they're just stay they're they're
good they're good stay what stay moist
oh my God audience are you starting off
with that stuff uh next time we got
Cruella Deville my fanfic stays tight
oh my gosh that was how we were doing
yeah
that's worse I know it's way worse I'm
very concerned about these fanfics guys
uh speaking of concerning fanfics we got
Tommy Bechtel hey guys so great to be
here thank you so much for having me uh
as always thank you to all the people in
the chat and my fanfic stays more loose
than a pile of roast beef left over at
an Arby's that ran out of business gosh
they got the meats oh oh I got the meat
guys I need to eat at Arby's please
don't disturb me like that what uh
if you love Horsey Sauce uh for every
hundred dollars today Cruella Deville
here will paint one of us like a
Dalmatian uh and we'll do a trick uh I'm
rolly Jessica can we get an example yeah
um speak
uh I'm I'm easily suggestible so don't
worry about that uh but hey it's Friday
let's get into it with some headlines
I see Shiny Shack said nobody likes
Arby's it's a conspiracy I I can't trust
this girl says I love Arby's yeah there
we go I can't read above the shiniest
people love their Arby's ah there are my
horses for our first headline today
let's talk about She-Hulk uh because one
of their writers Zeb Wells told
comicbook.com and I put this in here for
you koi that still man was almost a
cameo in She-Hulk I tried so hard and
you fell so far but yeah
uh this is what Zepp had to say also
love the name Zeb Wells great name great
name that's Michael's mind oh yeah well
if my middle name was that bike I went I
had a basketball Elementary School named
Zeb and uh he punched me in the stomach
and now we're not friends what's Zeb
short for Zebulon
you both said zebra die like it's a real
name it is real name and he loves the
Bible
sorry Sims I didn't read all of them
I've read the entire Bible front to back
and back to front
there you go okay I think my favorite
um my favorite Bible verse is uh Pizza
in the morning Pizza in the evening
Pizza adds up a time with pizzas on a
bag of oil you can eat pizza at any time
Papa John 4 20. yeah my favorite passage
Papa John 4 20. The Book of John uh
speaking of John Seb Wells had to say
this is what he said about still man he
said cool I think still man was probably
thrown in there at one point saracen he
started off as someone else we couldn't
get for some reason but they obviously
did get them yeah uh and then he also
said I think there is a character at
Marvel called The Matador and we
couldn't use him no do you think they
meant like they were gonna get someone
else to be not not to be saracen but
they were going to not use saris in a
different character
that's how he lives so long that's how
he got so tall uh Sarah said it sounds
like they wanted to use him and they're
like no you can't have it and they're
like okay and then they probably came
back and we're like okay you can use
them which is interesting I don't know I
think the idea of Stillman the fact that
I wanted the most why would they let him
have them yes there's still men coming
in another property do we get blatant
for systems I mean they're nice Sons
don't man born again wait we need one
more Avenger
the Young Avengers they need a tall
person yeah that is true that is true
their basketball team is almost formed
almost uh next headline Dwayne Johnson's
out there talking Black Adam uh it's a
week away the premieres next week uh
quiet I know you've seen it and the
Embargo is lifted right people are
putting their Roots I can give a social
link talk you can do a blurb I can do a
blurb well well first they someone
interviewed uh uh Mr rock at the at the
premiere
um and he had a very interesting thing
he said uh during this interview when
they kind of were like goading him they
were like is this you know is Black Adam
gonna take down Marvel is it gonna you
know reset the hierarchy of power uh is
it going to do all this thing uh and I
think Mr Johnson had a great response to
it I think we have a clip of it right
here we could show we don't want to be
marveling we want to be DC and how
weakness so so that's what I want I
don't want to take a bite of that Apple
uh I want to grab a new Apple
I think it was a good answer are you
supposed to be saying it's very
realistic very Down to Earth being like
they're doing incredible things over
there
to me like I do not understand it like
why not enjoy Comics I mean you know
it's like people love conflict they want
to have these rivalries they want to
have a hot sound bite that they could
put on the air uh and the rockets don't
have sports teams I think it's because
like we became the drugs no that's 100
true because I definitely am like this
is my team right this is my team I think
people need tribalism and it's weird
because like like Jeff Johnson and Kevin
feige are friends oh my God I haven't
everyone's making money such a joke I
have nerd tattoos so I'm like oh face
painted I think it goes back to Wolf
culture guys we're all seeking our own
wolf packs remember when they tried to
pit the Easter Bunny against Santa all
those years and eventually what they end
up doing excuse me Santa
teaming up and now they're married
they're married yeah
something else come from they come out
of eggs that's right that's why you have
eggs just yep we are getting uh our
first mix of kind of uh Black Adam
reviews there's some good reviews
there's some less good reviews why do
you want to give a social review I will
give a social review in that I went into
this wanting it to be a hierarchy
shifting experience and I left this
movie more optimistic for DC than I had
in a very long time right I had high
expectations left very happy and I think
it is a very powerful uh boost to what
DC can be and I I was shocked at how
much I loved it I had a really great
time
good and Hawkman uh deserves many many
franchises like I haven't seen that kind
of like him and Pierce Brosnan come out
of the gate like please everything and
uh yeah I was I was so impressed yeah
yeah we all want DC to do why we want
Marvel to do well more competitions
better for everyone so it keeps everyone
fresh so monopoly's boring yeah like no
one works hard when you're comfortable
yeah oh we know as a wrestling fan it
was great to see aew come to rise to
kind of push WWE to be better you'll
love to see uh you know as a huge North
Korea stand I was pretty happy with what
Putin's been doing the last few months
what that's great also new tweets so
different social review The Rock himself
uh I was so impressed at his like really
stoic but passionate performance because
a lot of times people like oh it's a
rock movie you go in for certain things
but he like worked his butt off like
this is a really different take on the
Rock and it feels like Black Adam that
impressed me as a comic fan yeah he
hasn't made me cry since the tooth fairy
and I I really want it you can't handle
the two I can't Fast Five tops for me
all that sweat gave me nice Black Adam
give uh uh people's elbow to anybody
gives a people's cheeky smile a few
times do we get a raise an eyebrow that
used to be a thing he had to do in
movies it was important I don't think he
has to do that anymore that's why he
took The Rock Johnson but at one point
he does go if you smell
what Black Adam
is cooking
I don't know what that's a reference to
um an additional Black Adam headline
here there's a rumor mill it's churning
out
crushed Reef that's what Mills do I
don't know uh oh whoa whoa there was a
rumor coming out that uh apparently star
girl was in an original draft of this
script and wasn't allowed to be used now
this is again this is a rumor we don't
have any confirmation on this uh Casey
Walsh on Twitter was kind of talking
about this they said that stargo was
originally important part of the cast
but the arrowverse
people would not let that character be
used I think they want to use the same
actress
but apparently it didn't work out and so
a lot of people are kind of uh saying
that like Cyclones character in this
film was maybe originally gonna where
star girl would have fit in
do you want me to do this oh if you want
to yeah well it's interesting because
the JSA setup's so different so it's
really interesting like how would we
have felt right like is she the Nexus
being of DC well I guess this this kind
of all goes all the way back to like
2019. I mean we've been working on this
movie for a while scripts for this while
so this could have been a very early
draft I don't know but very interesting
to see you know I think a lot of people
would have liked to see Stargirl kind of
come over it's always confusing with
like what's real with arrowverse and DCU
I don't know I I really like we talked
about it a lot I really wanted them to
do like a crisis where they like cleaned
up all the TV and film continuity and
kept who they wanted right because in
the comics that's totally Canon so you
just start fresh but I think both
franchises both Marvel and DC are gonna
do that at some point yeah I think
that's what Marvel's doing with Secrets
I think so your horse is a nice like
unplug it plug it back in yeah
okay this is just a side note because
Jay Washington has been on our show a
couple of times during one division do
you remember when Disney plus would like
just crash for a minute yeah no one
could use it yeah Jay was 2 reading at
Disney like a damn fool he was it was
like Non-Stop and he was like someone
take the cartridge out
this all takes so bad I feel like HBO
Max has problems I need to watch uh
House of the Dragons right sometimes
really I get those those like kind of
dots and I'm like oh come on that's part
of my like the She-Hulk moment because I
was like it's happening like they did a
really good job
I immediately went hey
and then I saw her start talking and I
was like oh are you Geniuses I'm an
idiot JJ ride me sitting in a Super Chat
saying Jessica looking phenomenal yeah
what else is new I keep sending in those
super checks folks if you want to see
these baby boys become baby dummies I
can uh another example go to camera two
this one over here
um Coy can you
um oh can you shake can you shake boy oh
good boy so suggestible look at my boys
he's that voice it's that voice like a
siren song I Would crash myself on the
Rocks right okay anyways next time
Marvel Zombies Marvel Zombies executive
producer Zeb Wells
well it's back again baby oh my God he's
back again he's revealed the episode
count for this upcoming spin-off series
now it's gonna be animated series kind
of based on the zombie what if Episode
we saw 46 episodes 46 episodes no I'm
just kidding it's four apples I was like
what you did not saying it's only gonna
be four episodes which I think is great
quick uh and it's gonna get a tvma
rating which is basically like an R
rating equivalent wow uh werewolf by
Knight was TV 14. it's like tvma it's
like Captain America gonna come in and
be like look at this hog
do we know how long the episodes are
gonna be we don't know which my thing is
like if this is for 22 minute episodes
just put them all together just make a
movie
but I am Groot was nice in those little
debts like I enjoyed those I don't like
that they at least fast forwarded the
Marvel intro every time that was a huge
relief but this is a big like this is a
good precedent for Deadpool and things
like this I like big moment I mean we've
all agreed that werewolf by night was a
huge success yeah I think these smaller
little things that they can do it's like
when you go and you buy a comic run
that's like six issues right in mini
series versus Maxi series versus ongoing
Series yeah I I love it I hope the
episodes are four hours long four 12
hours
time for that on the break room yeah uh
I am excited I I this thing does
I don't know how violent these are going
to be or Glory I'm wondering if they
leaned on a tvma because it's animated
and they just don't want parents being
like Oh animated Marvel thing because
there is so much animated Marvel
cartoons about the Avengers and stuff
that you can go watch that are not part
of the larger MCU Cannon but we've been
told before that like animated this kind
of Marvel animated stuff is Canon like
all the what-ifs Canon
I think the making it TV
I think they're making a tvma is the
they're like first let not the first but
like the notch it's like yeah this is
more adults watch our content than
children yeah I think it's beta testing
right because I mean the Deadpool show
got shut down because we weren't there
yet like the Donald Glover Deadpool show
getting shut down is I think the worst
thing that's happened like that's in pop
culture I'm crushed but like we could
have had something really special I
think this is a good way to be like is
there an audience for this yeah and I
think and there is and there is it's us
because we're the ones that are going to
the premieres we're the ones tweeting
about it all the time and we're the ones
getting angry and it's my nephew doesn't
get mad yeah by the time this comes out
it'll be 15 16 years people that were
two or 18. yeah
yeah I won't have it uh Brandon was
barely born I was barely born barely
born barely born let's get spooky folks
uh Halloween ends is coming out this
weekend uh I think it's gonna also be on
peacock very shortly after I think
immediately today with the last movie
too but people want to go see it's much
scary in theaters you know it was a
great theatrical experience yeah I liked
it in theater because you got to like
ooh and on experience like it's a very
twisty tourney you want the audience to
be with you have you seen Halloween
all right
they had that Thursday night Premiere
last night obviously they got 5.4
million in Thursday which is up 11 from
Thursday night previews of Halloween
kills so it's already doing a little
better it might have a pretty good
little weekend I'm not gonna see it I
will say the coolest thing about the
premiere was Jamie Lee Curtis got a
standing ovation they put thank you
Jamie behind her it was a vignette of
all the final girls like thanking her
they made like a compilation it was so
special she came to yours uh she dipped
out of ours that's cool
the small folk don't get to see Jamie
Lee Curtis uh yeah I might turn I mean I
hate scary movies I'm a little scared
honestly if you you knowing that you're
you don't like scary movies and you
choose I'm sorry to say this but you
choose Halloween I would be mad at you
go watch Jeepers Creepers
I just knocked over my thing and you're
watching yeah
so good but I think you'd be too afraid
of Black Friday
would be I think Ethan Hawke is scary
and he's so funny
um so before we get into our main
discussion today which we're super uh
excited to get into real quick we want
to remind you uh they've been sponsoring
the show all week Magic the Gathering
Arena uh you guys know Magic the
Gathering it's a fun card game well now
you can play it digitally you can play
on your phone your computer your tablet
whatever you want this year Magic the
Gathering is celebrating its 30th
Anniversary it's bigger than ever an MTG
Arena you can you know you can learn to
play the game you collect the cards
challenge your friends play against
people build your own custom Decks that
show off your favorite fandom because
they have all sorts of different stuff
horror sci-fi fantasy all that great
stuff uh I never played magic as a kid
but I've learned to play because of
Magic the Gathering Arena it's really
fun you can't screw up because you're
trying to break the rules it won't let
you which is the hardest thing for me
about magic the Gathering are all the
rules so many rules so many rules but
MTG arena is a great entry point to get
into it or uh for the first time or get
back into magic if you've lapsed your
play style like I said you could do it
on your mobile phone your tablet your
desktop wherever you want and it's free
to play baby uh and if you need help
learning to play the game they got a
great YouTube channel so if you look in
our description right now you can find a
link to that you can click and you can
download Magic the Gathering arena for
free there's also a link uh you could
check out their YouTube page once you're
done watching this show uh and learn how
to play Magic gather and get some tips
do all that great stuff check it out
Magic the Gathering Arena do it today
sounds fun super fun it's very fun maybe
that's what I'll do all weekend is that
all weekend I'm gonna play Marvel snap
all right
thank you yeah that's it I don't like
wearing gloves I don't know how rich
people do it maybe it's because I'm not
rich maybe maybe I don't have the rich
skin yet it's like do you have to talk
like you feel like it feels like I'm in
an extra skin I always feel numb I
always feel like why why can't I feel
and then I can't yeah it's another skin
maybe I'll start to love it okay so it's
gonna another skin more we're gonna cut
the commercial for a few minutes here
guys we'll be back
Jessica is like discovering things about
herself right now I think I like the way
let me paint your faces
um another Rumor Mill for you right
because yeah yeah this is definitely a
big big time rumor rumor meal rumor meal
you guys Harrison Ford is reportedly
playing Thunderbolt Ross in the upcoming
Captain America New World Order and the
Thunderbolts film so you're saying
Harrison Ford and Jeff loveness are both
in the MCU what is the connective tissue
between those two people
oh they're one degree away from Tommy
back to all years ago Tommy incepting
the MCU interview I am the key to all of
this Tommy as the beyonder confirmed
without me there is no Harrison Ford
there is no MCU there is no Jeff
loveness so I'm waiting for my call boys
and that a call will be answered on a
black phone oh
so yeah
why are they putting why why is Harrison
Ford I was going to ask you the same
question well if you don't know and if
this is where you find out I apologize
William Hurt did pass away last year uh
and he originally he's been uh Thaddeus
Thunderbolt Ross away from uh The
Incredible Hulk all the way through uh
uh last year's Black Widow film uh he's
shown up in six of them I think yeah
five or six of the DMC movies
this is including Incredible Hulk yes
yes yes
um but like you know and famously in the
comics he becomes the Red Hulk which is
something we speculated for a while
especially as they were keeping kind of
Thunderbolt Ross around then of course
the actors passing probably
through a wrench and all that but now
there's these kind of reports coming out
and Disney hasn't come from this
officially Marvel hasn't confirmed it
officially Harrison hasn't confirmed it
officially but we're on the street is
and a lot of sources are starting to
cover this news uh that Harrison Ford is
going to be cast as the Thunderbolt rust
that we know so
brother what does that mean for
um
I don't know who I am anymore
um do you think we're gonna
acknowledge he's been gone for so long
like what are we gonna can we easily
make that jump what was the last moment
we was in I point to you Black Widow but
that is up 2016. yeah but that takes
place before end game and so what's the
last one in chronology well we saw him
in in game
Civil War was like his biggest comeback
role but we still saw him in and there's
a lot of stuff that happened between end
game and what we have now right right
yeah and especially with fans like that
but always seen him in a movie was was
Black Widow but that takes place before
all that but yeah so how is he no what
are you gonna say well value you said
okay that's where I'm like how is he
gonna address the Falcon in the Winter
Soldier situation is it just I think
he's gonna get down cheeteled or he's
gonna get I think
they're just gonna replace him and not
say anything I mean this has happened a
couple times right yeah you know tower
being the famous Cassie Lang we're gonna
have our third Cassie Lang uh in the
next question which is different that's
different they're age so you kind of
accept the changes there
um but yeah this is like a pretty high
profile where you can I think it's an
easy enough thing to do with this
character though because you're gonna
have it maybe in a couple scenes as
human and then maybe he gets stuck as a
red Hulk like he does in the comics and
maybe that is a precautionary measure
where like Val gets to take over yeah
like maybe you know we we trusted you
you did an experiment you can't be
trusted I'm running the team you're on
the team you think that okay two
questions let's answer the first one
first you think Val wouldn't have
stopped him I think she wouldn't have
had the power to and then I think she
has the only she's lower than him right
now I think right now and then she's
like look what happened and you let this
guy do what he wanted now he's on the
team I have her gloves
um I have Val's gloves
um and then my second question what I I
just because for me if you're gonna
bring in Red Hulk I really want to see
the Red She-Hulk so I really want to see
but this is the only time I'll say it I
really want to see that Betty Ross I
think we could so do you think you want
to live Tanner back
I don't mind but I wouldn't I guess I'd
want a new one because Liv is like live
we can't just order them up like
microwave ovens bring in Jennifer
Connelly from Eric Bana just confuse all
of us
for why not I I think is there I mean to
me
there's a chance that it's like hey we
need you on set for two days then you're
gonna turn into Red Hulk and then you're
going to be doing here's a wheelbarrow
well that's that's a great point right
Harrison Ford's 80 years old but he's
currently filming a TV show that he's
the leader I mean he's working in this
Yellowstone he's really active he's also
still going to do that Anna Jones well
he shot that should roll well he
famously said it d23 I'm not doing any
more Indiana Jones movies I'm done
falling down for you for you guys
will fall down for us I mean think about
roses really need to fall because he's
not old
and in theory they don't even they mo
cap like right you know uh uh someone
Hulk and She-Hulk right Tatiana
masalani's on set but I imagine it's
just got doubles on set but like what if
they're just body doubling him and
they're gonna write William or John
hurt's face over William Hurt John Hurt
William Hurt William Hurt we said John
heard earlier did I say John Williams I
don't know they're gonna put William
hurt's face over him like they did
Grandma Tarkin and Rogue one like
Harrison will just be there like walking
around well
my wife was like well who who does scar
turn into and I was like well Scott
doesn't turn into it he's just a child
because she's like who's playing Scar
and I was like well nobody's a Hulk well
it could just be a thing where like they
their technology is now at the point
where I don't think anyone was standing
there no maybe it's a reference point I
don't know but I don't feel like she's
in a moocab I think yeah someone in the
chat I think it was filmed you said what
if uh he didn't even say what if he says
Val equals red hole do you think
or even if it's not it could she could
be like the Red She-Hulk and never raw
somehow do we have two red hulks one's
red shield but there's all that space
above the Thunderbolts it's just all
Hulk's Abomination that's what I said
there's gonna be like five of them Mount
Rushmore of this is kind of a
fascinating thing to me about this rumor
is is that they say they mentioned
Captain America new world order as
something that he's gonna be in and
Thunderbolts also which makes sense
because Thunderbolt is named after him
and I see a world where like
Thaddeus was using Val to set this up
because in whatever government capacity
he is he can't do it directly or
something I don't know that makes sense
right but is ever or is Thunderbolt Ross
that important I think he's gonna have
to have this character at least for one
more movie maybe two more I think it's
gonna be like he goes to the leader and
convinces the leader to turn him into
Hulk because he's jealous and then he
gets stuck as Red Hulk and then we've
got voice over from now on including
thumbnails I
he doesn't give that
he doesn't I don't know I need I need a
bigger thing I need those steaks that
were Betty Ross dying and him spiraling
and being like bring my daughter back
and also change me into the Hulk so I
can go kill the Hulk throughout the
movies William Hurt be like very
vindictive vindictive again but it
wasn't never to that limit of like
change me to look like the person I hate
does that make sense but that's why I
think like they need multiple movie
setup right like the leader coming in is
the villain you're gonna need more Hulk
action yes and then I feel like if
anyone's gonna make you feel like
vengeful Harrison Ford with his point of
Justice right like if there's some point
points at you you would ever asked I was
imagining I was imagining that he would
jump in and immediately do this and I
was like no I think I would need to see
like two movies at least that's why I
think he becomes it in in Thunderbolts
but we have him as Thunderbolt Ross as
Thunderbolt runs and then the end the
leader turns him um I like hockey one
it's the gloves when does Thunder the
Thunderbolts come out do we know it's
it's almost a year or not it's a few
months after oh here you go thank you
thank you uh Thunderbolts is in 2024
July of 20. but it's no but it's the
next thing after Captain America is what
I'm saying they're very close I think I
think it ends with him becoming right
now okay and then then Thunderbolts he's
already read Hulk so I think he does one
movie where he's the lion sure human and
then the end of the leader turns him
into Red Hulk and then going into
Thunderbolts he's already read Hulk and
then at the end so going into Secret
Wars we'll have a red hole potentially
if Harrison Ford wants to do voice over
for like I mean and that's just yeah
he's not falling over for that
um but I think that the only way to
replace an actor you know that's been
with us this long is you get someone
like Harrison Ford right you need that
kind of Gravitas because we're getting
since we're late we're already leaning
to like what uh the Thunderbolts and
what um Captain America can do what
order kids mean what does this mean
Thunderbolt Ross coming back for
She-Hulk and all the other hulks like
going forward I know that we don't know
if we're getting World War Hulk movie or
a planet Hulk movie but it's like he
would have to be a big part of that as
well right theoretically I mean it seems
like Captain America 4 is becoming like
a Hulk movie which is interesting I know
that is very strange when they said the
leader wreck at t23 was like huh so oh
wait okay Captain America New World
Order yeah when you say Captain America
four I thought it was Chris Evans I said
wait he's coming back well you missed
the news yesterday
it's odd that the same Wilson Cat movie
has this much Hulk in it yeah that
element so I'm really curious well and
them bringing scar in at the end of
She-Hulk it does seem like they either
want to do some parts of world war hawk
or some parts of Planet what's so tricky
is planet Hulk is so about Hulk being
rageful and he was like in a polo yes
like when Paul came back like Fast and
Furious in his like family outfit I was
like that's not Planet Halton well but
if something happens now that there's a
kid
you're stuck on that you because you
even pitched you're like he's gonna be
cute and I want scar to be the worst the
worst thing that happened to the MCU
like if I say worse I mean like in the
comics he was just all he knew was
fighting that's all he wanted to do was
fight and he was aggressive and I even
pitched this on Rook Theory that's going
to come out tomorrow that how are you
gonna have this sun not be so like burnt
by his dad being gone through developing
years and though yes he aged quickly
because in sakar we don't know how time
really works but I still want him to be
like you're my dad you weren't there and
you're not even my dad well it might
still be a six-year-old we don't know
how old he is yeah he just looks good
real quick that's why he's so exactly
like it hurts to grow yeah yeah it hurts
to grow yeah I love the idea we all want
to see Hulk again right yeah Sparkle
it's fun but like the uncontrollable
Hulk the angry Hulk like I was hoping
that yeah him just even seeing
Abomination would just break smart Hulk
or like I kind of had I was joking with
Eric about the idea that the
Intelligentsia was Hulk like and Bruce
had no idea that Hulk was like when he
was sleeping like taking over and like
the other guys just an internet
trolls because that's the thing I want
Hulk back and have just been like laying
in weight waiting to maybe Tyler dies in
Captain America four and that turns
Thunderbolt into Red Hulk and that
pisses Hulk off enough to become angry
again
sit down you you wait over here yeah
it's Hulk in time that's so sad Samos is
like this is my movie they're like that
works in She-Hulk and it doesn't work
here if you have a double Catalyst of
angry Hulk and red Hulk from Liv Tyler
dying yeah I love that I'm here for that
uh and lastly really quick what and I
know this is we don't like to do this
but we're gonna do it what are the cons
the Thunderbolt Ross coming back
it's the first journalist at s Harrison
for the comics yeah yeah right I mean I
have seen some people being
grumpy he doesn't lie Marvel movies we
don't know that you don't know that and
we've also had plenty of grumpy old apps
so this is a Shameless name drop I've
met Harrison Ford twice the nicest guy
like unless you kiss you on the forehead
I mean not that not that nice but like
he's got Santa energy he's just a jolly
guy when you're not like high as hell
he's just Jolly we saw him at d23 he
came up very emotionally invested
uh Michael Keaton who we love is Batman
who we love this vulture anytime you're
asking about comic book [ __ ] he's like I
don't know I didn't watch any of them
about Star Wars like he's been talking
about it for 40 years I'm just so
worried about the first guy that's like
well in the comic Red Hulk like I just
that is I'll never forget you can find
it out there when they it was announced
that Kurt Russell was gonna be ego and
they Someone caught him on a red carpet
like that day and was like what this
dude's about you being an ego and he's
like I have no idea what the hell you're
talking about
they never I love well because who was
the celebrity that was like yeah put me
in as um a a cat a cat a cat thing I can
do it and I was like girl come on stop
at least research before you go in there
no it was a girl that has the same last
name as Kane and was like I should be in
the Marvel movies because we have the
same last name
yeah
his name is King and she's like oh so
there's kangs in the ends
I have nothing wrong I don't think
there's a real con to having Thunder
Ross come back the only thing is I had
so which still could happen I wanted Val
to take that mantle so bad because
Thunderbolt Ross I think like how Coy
did say is very like headstrong and
hot-headed and doesn't really think
before he does a lot of the things he
does oh I'm referring back to Incredible
Hulk really but uh Val does and I think
Val's very calculated and very very
sneaky and I would love to see her in
that position yeah catch me maybe she
will you know they couldn't he could
only be back for one movie She's also on
the team she's gonna have like she will
have to have something otherwise it's
just like hi I'm from Seinfeld I'm on
this team this could also be like when
you visit a red box at your local
7-Eleven and you're like oh I've never
heard of this Bruce Willis movie yeah
and he's in it for two minutes
this could be a five million dollar
Cameo yeah yeah which is urge like I'm
gonna I'm more excited that Harrison
Ford is part of the MCU to find out what
Lord came in my the do you have
something no keep going the conspiracy
theory part of my brain is like is this
Marvel kind of testing the waters of
like
anyone that was in the infinity Saga
right from Iron Man all the way through
and game
are they gonna like soft test like what
if we just recast does anyone care
because like as every year like you know
there's a a person watching a Marvel
movie for the first time right in their
first Marvel movie now post-end game
they can kind of play around with it's
up to you to go back and see who this
guy was yeah or this this uh woman was
especially for Secret Wars when they do
hard reset like is it I mean we are
eventually gonna have a new Tony Stark
right I do not into that actor but it's
gonna happen it'll happen and one that's
the way you know hopefully people want
to see it and like telling a different
Universe do whatever you got to do we'll
accept it um we're consumers we'll eat
it up I just wanted to read them
I just want to read a few soups oh yeah
send in those super chats I want to be a
puppy so yeah they want to be puppies
they want to be my dogs uh so filmjuice
said all the original Avengers went
through a trial by fire to become a
cohesive team is there a little
entitlement present among the Next
Generation nepotism absolutely and
absolutely not
um because I think I told yeah
um I think there's some that will and
some that won't I think it will take
scar unless scar is going to be
replacing like oh these are for The
Avengers not Young Avengers I was like
if he's replacing I think some will go
to Young Avengers some will go to actual
Avengers will be the action yeah and I
was like because they're all going to be
in their late 30s I was like they're
going to use scar to replace hulkling
possibly you're gonna have that
relationship it's Cassie Lane's
character statue statue yes that's her
statue stature stature it's like she's
giant she's stuck oh yeah I am gravitas
good name good name but also it's not
like Hawkeye's child is it's Kate Bishop
it's not nepotism completely it's people
that wanted to become superheroes I'm
sure they'll probably throw in and also
like Miss Marvel's not an episode right
yeah I think it's just gonna be like you
gotta earn it right you gotta I think
we'll see stature earn it and three you
sound like Todd
um oh boy why do they all got to be
female oh boy I do don't sit me next to
either these two
you made me think of like Martin's
daughter like on the farm looking out
the window seeing like Clinton Kate like
they're just being like that used to be
me
I mean that would be a great villain
first for sure jealous Glenn Barton's
daughter her name
yeah that's true it's Teresa's daughter
I could have been in a suit my dad
directed these movies and my other dad
used to trade me to the Hawkeye uh Bucky
Barnes says hi my brother Bechtel
brother Brown's got this weekend Buck
come on Lulu Brown I said who do the
Browns have this weekend
he's a Browns fan also Jason morante
says koi for dum dum Dugan I am
available or for Carnation
never is I really want them to go back
and make a howling Commando series dude
wouldn't that be so fun Captain Carter
comes back like you do the 60s stuff and
that's how you bring back Chris Evans do
a little little throwback uh Garth
McMurray says scar is portrayed by will
dusner I always pronounce his name wrong
who was Joey zarick in the CW's star
girl I agree with koi that's a car will
fill in for the Hulk Lane and the Young
Avengers
they had an actor this actor Will yeah
we'll Do's nurse okay
I was like there was someone standing
there he wasn't in the credits oh he
wasn't no that way it didn't get leaked
it's like they don't use the
teleprompter at d24 but they don't want
to take the time
um
this is me said with Disney plus
becoming more Canon can people without
it enjoy the movies has Marvel created a
problem which might hurt the franchise
oh so far no so far everybody bundled it
up with Hulu and ESPN so also like no
one I feel like Wanda went the other way
like one division set up a very
different thing than what doctor strange
it's almost like the movie went
differently I think maybe as we go
forward you'll need it like Loki season
two seems to be more cohesive but yeah I
don't I don't know you know I think
they're not a not worried about that and
B I I think I haven't seen a movie yet
that feels confusing
I think the TV shows maybe feel
confusing if you've never watched a
Marvel movie yeah but I don't think it
works the other way it's just very
rewarding my mom was just text me and be
like like she did first she helped she
went how do they always know where to
get people in the sling Rings because it
just randomly appears and I was like
there's a there's a spell that I'm sure
that well you have to Envision your
target right yeah because he had to say
it yeah yeah and Jordan Ragnarok they
had to like do uh an entire enchantment
oh so sorry sorry I'm trying to go
through this quickly you guys
unpronounceable says wait Gary Oldman is
Doom okay
I'm here for as long as they do
ourselves as long as he enters the Gary
Oldman in our final Super Chat Jessica
looking phenomenal
wonderful oh and Franco just said in a
Super Chat saying Jess love the outfit
thank you all the new lovely characters
we have seen which one do you want as a
plushie oh man thing oh man thing which
we need to get into we need to get into
it all right so before we get to all the
sexy fun times uh we want to thank our
sponsors for the show today sponsors
like aspiration you know making small
decisions every day to help the planet
can have a big impact over time like
making small sexy decisions every day
can have a big impact over time uh tell
me about G-Unit but hey if you keep your
money in most standard bank accounts
they're lending your money out to fund
oil companies and call companies no uh
and companies that take rabbits and
grind them up into powder just for fun
uh but switch to the planet side and get
aspiration aspiration it's a fossil fuel
free card and it lets you save the
planet because every time you swipe that
card you can round up your purchase to
help plant a tree they've already been
planting over 100 million trees and they
want to do way more uh best of all
there's no credit check with aspiration
no overdraft fees you just pay what you
think is fair even if that's zero
because money shouldn't stand in the way
of you doing the right thing make your
dollars make a difference open an
aspiration account at aspiration.com
break room debit and move your money out
of fossil fuels help save the planet
with your aspiration debit card open
your account at aspiration.com break
room debit today aspiration.com break
room debit terms and conditions apply ah
we also want to thank our other sponsor
today athletic greens we are huge fans
of their ag1 powder which Brandon and I
can't get enough of this morning we we
drink it every morning it's the only
thing keeping me alive we get one big uh
cup two scoops because there's two boys
Lunch Counter that's right ah every
scoop of Veggie one has 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens
this special blend of ingredient
supports a lot of Health stuff including
better sleep quality mental Clarity and
alertness
you have hilarious ag-1 is one thing you
can do every single day to take good
care of yourself reclaim your health and
arm your immune system with convenient
daily nutrition it's just one scoop and
a cup of water every day that's it to
make it easier athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase if you're going on to Spain
take ag-1 with you yeah I'm going to Las
Vegas this weekend so much
with it I'm going to Pound Town
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com break room again that
is athleticreams.com break room to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
delicious delicious it's time for
mandatory fun
says y'all my husband's so invested in
the break room we forgot to feed our dog
we have something in common afraid
girl's husband and I hate those doggies
stop dogs let them know it's child down
time
feed those dogs and there won't be food
and the doggies Bulls this Christmas uh
all right anyway uh it's mandatory fun
when I get my three best friends in the
whole world to sit down and have a
little fun with me whether they want to
or not now
uh this is the same mandatory fun as
yesterday
hang on scroll down I think it might be
underneath it
last night I broke into Marble's
comments oh my gosh the official erotic
parody company of the MCU oh and I found
a story that really really got my spider
since tingling okay so I decided to
challenge my friends to make some other
nerd nerdy erotic fan fiction a little
geeky uh geeky fun time fanfic so uh
anyone want to go first and you guys all
worked really hard and fast uh on yours
just uh pumping out those words
let's go first sure go ahead first I
won't tell you the title this it'll be
revealed the players in this erotic game
if some of these are good can we get
them published in Wire magazine yes
uh-huh okay and The Story begins I think
that's all we're going to cover for
today we'll regroup again in the morning
have a good night he clicked off the
speakerphone and let out a soft sign
there was still plenty of work left
waiting for him tonight scripts that
need notes previous segments to review a
host of merch items that need approval
but what he needed more than anything
right now was
release
engaging the electric lock on his door
he quickly scanned through the programs
on his hard drive until he found the
precise one he was looking for and
dialed it up hello Kevin is there a
reason you are utilizing me so late in
the evening
Edith's soft voice played over the
speakers built into the side of Kevin's
metallic chassis the soft vibrations
formed in the speaker's magnetic coils
by Edith's pronunciation of his name
sent shivers down his power cables that
hung low from the ceiling Oh I thought
we might take some time to aggregate our
algorithms if that's something you would
be interested in Kevin's processor word
nervously in the empty Silence of his
chamber as he waited for her response I
would be eager to engage you
electronically Edith cude but wouldn't
it be a violation of the inner work
relationship protocols set forth by the
I.T department at the studio
don't worry Edith I have removed those
protocols whoa immediately Edith
incentive torrent of coded binary
language directly into Kevin's
motherboard causing his heat sink to
become engorged not wasting a moment he
quickly took control it's time to update
your processor with an immediate dose of
solid-state Ram his metallic frame word
and clicked as the lights across the
studio lot began to dim from the sudden
diversion of electric power on the grid
oh my God oh my God that was too hot for
TV oh boy I'll go next that's gonna be a
tough act to follow I know I don't want
to go out there all right
chapter one chapter one chapter one
okay
chapter one him
her pleasure was his business and
business was Boo me sure the female body
had always confused him like one of
those complex church organs his grandma
used to make him take lessons on but
those lessons had paid off or so he
thought based on the giggles and moans
coming from above this was his magnum
opus
and he was the conductor hands moving
and swaying to the bodily beat
when his concerto was finished he
inhaled deeply and breathed his sigh of
relief
another satisfied customer
what chapter two
her oh
is this almost over she thought to
herself he had been down there for over
an hour well she commended his work
ethic the overall service was less than
the five-star treatment she was used to
his technique was like a drunk man
blowing on the wrong end of a harmonica
there was no rhythm and the sounds were
disturbing if they weren't so sad
she hoped you didn't notice she was on
her phone the whole time but if she was
being honest with herself she didn't
really care as abruptly as he had
started he came to a sputtering end good
try she thought lying to herself what
erotic fanfiction chapter three oh then
is it okay if we leave together he asked
almost timidly no you leave and I'll
wait 10 minutes and then leave she
answered she could see this hurt him
so we don't get caught by the paparazzi
she added good thinking he said and with
that Todd
around his expensive jacket and exited
the room finally that makes sense some
alone time Titania thought to herself
her phone's beeping and vibrating every
two seconds that makes sense
I love the POV switches yeah mine is
that did I do rock that was a little
rashimon yeah little place to be on the
Pines mine's not sexy at all but see if
you guys can guess it okay and then
you'll know why it's not sexy cobwebs
rats and death surrounds me sharp spikes
of bone puncture my skin this isn't my
body this isn't my skin not my home or
love even awaits me I smell them near
and memories of past encounters dig out
my brain a slave to his desires a moment
of bliss and the quickest release the
moment he reached for me I shuddered his
hands but eyes no colder than I he pulls
me in closer and bears I close my eyes
squirming in his arms I yell to the
darkness do you know who I am I am your
king
he says no king of mine has ever looked
so delectable no he encapsulates me as
he lowers me into a pool of water he
gently wets my hair and labels a bit of
milk of the poppy onto my eroded chest
our moan and ecstasy as his tongue
Trails over my cadaverous neck ah he
lets his hands run over my body with no
restraint watching me clean up my
festering wounds he says my servant my
play thing my king I respond with one
last breath my love
it's uh death okay oh all right all
right oh is that who but serious yeah he
was reaching out to dance oh I couldn't
tell because my TV was too dark you
bring this up way too often it since I
have a bad TV okay it's not the show's
fault are we ready
so uh we got number two all right oh boy
a benevolent creature has been flirting
with me across the bar seducing me with
their red eyes and undulating thick
muscular tentacles oh my God ribbed but
for whose pleasure oh
curiosity ravages me to the point I
can't take it anymore once their eyes
peer up through long
eyelashes why not suggestively to the
unisex bathroom damn damn boy I look
over my shoulder and the cocaine
bashfully sauntered in oh oh so quietly
for someone so massive they move like a
field mouse
do you like teasing me I point
they respond
I've had it
I'm reduced to a caveman
I already have my hands gripping their
solid green high I slam them against the
baby changing station wow the frame
bites into their back and they whimper
their hand comes to my throat as their
weight sinks over top of me we're taking
as much as we can get like it's been
years with them now turned facing the
wall they big
so I look up
up they're turgid drunk into those two
Crimson orbs of man thing and I ask is
that
what you wanted man thing oh I I had a
cigarette I hate this I need to take a
shower it's gonna be ice cold after that
these will be available uh to the FBI I
guess we're gonna have to turn these
over a second I thought it was Valkyries
oh my God that was we don't have polls
but let us know who you like most in the
chat I mean someone's got to get their
face painted after that it's got to be
quick
needs to get his face painted your face
I'll go to the movies after as well pink
boys I have a makeup remover okay so you
can't have it
I haven't I'll hold it in front of you
um
well I'm looking at the pole right now
and it looks like it was a dead tie 25
for everything oh beautiful beautiful uh
we did thank you all our super Chatters
that got us over our goal Redemption go
for today I have Patron saying Jess have
you seen terrific fire too I haven't
seen the second one she hasn't seen this
wait no I think I no I just watched it
with my friend and I fell asleep at like
just right at terrifier too yeah I think
but I think they're the same but I might
not be right I might not be right I just
watched it and I I should go back and
watch it fully you guys have been busy
with She-Hulk I'm finally done yeah Myra
she's right Colin uh film just saying uh
you done fed my dogs with these readings
whoa
this is erotic thank you yeah I like
that literally describing it literally
describing it the MJ 2997 uh saying that
Super Chat saying can't wait for the
Andor segment uh oh yeah we might have
an indoor segment today that is
pertinent to our discussion number two
oh that is Department because that is my
record that is my recommendation yeah as
it is Friday here at the breaker we're
having a great day we hope you guys have
had a great week we've had a great week
with you uh saying goodbye to Tasha we
are we are shifting them
uh ship Titania is the other one so
Brandon and I are both the creators of
those shipping fandoms we always turned
we always to an animal look at cutie
little car thank you
she loves those puppies I live for first
I worship first all right you were
saying yeah so as we as we end our at
our week you know I want to go around
the table see if you guys have any uh
recommendations for things you're
watching that you're reading uh films
anything like that doesn't have to be
harmful it doesn't have to be so sorry
yes I'm so sorry put you guys in the
chat are so horny
this month
no stop don't read that no encouraging
them further all right this isn't TBR we
are we are good hosts
I guess listen to me
this is a great weekend God damn it oh
my God this is a great weekend think
about everything you've ever done in
your life or typed into a chat you know
normally when I call you guys trash I'm
kind of joking but my God uh watch Andor
thirsty catch up on Andor guys it's the
weekend you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna make an admission right now I
haven't watched rings of power yet I've
only watched half of the first episode
this weekend I'm gonna catch up on Rings
the final episode came out this week
yeah I'm gonna watch it uh before and
after the Buffalo Bills absolutely
destroy the Kansas City Chiefs on Sunday
that's right my prediction Buffalo 375
Kansas City negative four oh that's
quite a score is ears are flipped I
can't oh it's like it's like this way
so bad okay I'm trying to say bye for
the show Tom my turn off your mic no
they've got it here no God turn off his
mic um what are you watching Jessica you
know what I started watching last night
what's that
um was the um Muppets Haunted Mansion
yeah so I'm re-watching a lot and
because of it I was like I'm gonna watch
a muppet scaper a great Caper and then I
was like I'm gonna also watch Muppets
Take Manhattan so I'm re-watching all My
Muppet stuff and it holds up and it's a
Treasure Island Muppets
Tim Curry is so good I rewatched that
one twice because I was like that was
good I love it so much I even liked the
Muppet movie they made uh with the one
with Jason yeah I like that one good
good songs in that one any
recommendations from you I gotta I want
to do a sequel to my cat real quick okay
because I feel like we had a pair we got
a book in it right yeah so
rough
[Music]
it's terrible it's good with Keralis
today next to you too
I wanted the gift and then for for the
sequel uh I mean for the for the
recommendation uh I just started
Midnight Club I'm a big Flanigan guy
yeah so good it has the most jump scares
in a single look it's very intense but I
will recommend things that I have
finished I just saw moonage Daydream
which was uh the David bowie.com
it's as much uh I did I saw it as huge
that good but it's like an experience
more than documentary because I I felt I
got introspective I like felt like
burning man it was more of like a visual
auditory experience I wasn't I felt it
though like I walked out like did I
accidentally dose myself uh so I really
appreciate that and then uh clerks three
is now available on digital and uh Kevin
Smith moves me in the world to me
because that's okay well I got started
hosting because of Kevin so like that
yeah
of course fan is it is it important it
might be my favorite
like I wept a lot and it changed my view
of what Kevin can do it's beautiful you
did they're still very well it's the
sincerity of post-hearted tech Kevin
with the punk rock of Clerks ah it's
beautiful okay uh did you know that the
person who directed Muppets Haunted
Mansion is the same person who played
the giant Scottish guy and werewolf my
Knights I did not know what it works uh
with them a lot Kirk hammage I think is
his name I was the punk in Star Trek
something what I'll recommend is if you
enjoyed uh pug and She-Hulk uh and you
haven't watched the other two he is
great on a show called the other two I
mean it's on HBO Max yeah two quick
Seasons very funny Molly Shannon's in it
and it's incredible so good he's so good
he's so different everything he does
he's very funny and he was great on
She-Hulk but he gets a lot more time to
shine on the other two and he's really
great in that so I highly highly
recommend it uh the MJ 2997 setting a
Super Chat who is the better hero koi
dog or still want to go home
easily wins that one
which is like a combination of uh Kirk
Hammett from Metallica also sounds like
a delicious yeah I would order that
thank you Gregory a Robbins I needed
that uh I would have looked like a fool
tonight at my dinner party that I'm
going to oh well let's make sure you get
to that dinner party we want to thank
you guys for being with us here today
and all week we'll be back next week
with a full week no holidays on Monday
uh so make sure you join us right here
on the break room live go ahead and like
the video if you haven't already please
do that uh be sure to check out
Jessica's She-Hulk breakdown for the
finale which will be coming out on it
already came out it already came out
yeah
show oh okay great uh so make sure you
check that out uh have a great rest of
your weekend stay thirsty stay thirsty
write some fanfic this weekend uh and
we'll join you here tomorrow uh we love
you guys Leia's guidance have a great
weekend